leonard fournette apparently isn't the
long-term answer at running back for the
jacksonville jaguars i thought he was
going to be great this year sims agreed
with me i got him in both my fantasy
teams nobody cares
let me tell you something
i and and i i say this
hesitantly because it takes a
significant amount of courage to put on
that uniform and walk onto that field
and be out there with the biggest
strongest fastest athletes that
the united states of america has to
offer now look i know you could say well
basketball players talk
the full package all the different
skills there's no athlete like a
professional football player especially
from the standpoint of the
violence that can be inflicted upon you
when you're out there so it takes a high
degree of courage to just be on the
field with that said
i feel like lena fernett doesn't want to
get hit i feel like he gets the ball and
you never have those dreams where you're
in slow motion and everybody else is
moving at normal speed and no matter
what you do you're like running in mud i
feel like leonard fournette every time
he gets the ball he goes from running in
mud to bracing for impact instead of
delivering the blow now there was one
point last night where he delivered a
nice blow uh and then it said there were
flashes he had the long run near the end
of the game but not enough it's not
sustained it's not consistent he's
always been that way you know he'd have
a big run to pad his stats but the grind
it out
process just it's not good enough and i
thought he'd be significantly better
this year he's not and that's another
decision that the jaguars are gonna have
to make do they keep him for the fourth
year of his contract remember there's a
pending fight over his guaranteed money
and the jaguars have attacked it they've
tried to void it it's subject to an
arbitration it hasn't been resolved yet
but it could make it a lot easier for
the jaguars to move on for leonard
fournette next year if they decide this
guy is simply not getting it done and
based on what we saw last night even
though the jaguars won he is not getting
it done and he's a guy that they took in
the
first round of the 2017 draft with the
likes of patrick mahomes and desean
watson and christian mccaffrey on the
board
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports